are you going to show them your fights
uh he asked the other day for it because
i'm always watching he sees me watching
it and then i showed him he's like jesus
christ because it doesn't really look
like we have a shaved head
yeah he's like that's you papa boom boom
because of uh pow pow
like pat that's pop dad doing pow-pow
he's like why would you do that and then
we were driving the other day he goes
i'm gonna do palpatio no you're not
you don't want him to fight no hell no
no rich kid listen
name the best toughest rich kid you know
right now not that i'm that rich but i'm
just saying like no no i'm ready the
kids don't come from that like he's
gonna have too many options be a fighter
do you oh you think people get into
fighting because they don't have options
100 yeah the best ones don't do it
because
they could have went to you know mit
no i understand that but like are you
saying
especially because my son's not gonna be
small right like both of them be big
they're gonna play football like there's
no guarantee fighting's too rough
like you know dana white's the most
famous man in mixed martial arts he goes
fighting is not a career it's just what
he say it is it's in it's
opportunity it's not a career though
he's like this business isn't a career
for anybody
because it's except for the very few
it's a three-year what's the average i
think two and a half two and a half
years after that's like a running back
in the nfl
yeah even theirs is three and a half but
the running back in the nfl
is at least guaranteed a certain amount
of money he's at least getting money
but one of these does not create this
opportunity you know so he's just like
do you think there will be a point in
time
because right now to me all of the best
athletes
play either football or basketball
because it's life-changing money
the only one making life-changing money
in the ufc is conor mcgregor
so d you don't think there'll be a time
where you see like some of the great
athletes be like
you know what that's what i want to do
as opposed to basketball or football or
too tough
it's too tough it's not the first option
it's just not
yeah it's two like in punch in the face
it's not fun no the practices are a
nightmare like there's no off season
the notoriety is not even close to what
you'd get if you're like you know in the
nba or
well the guarantees the corrupt you know
like there's steps to get to the nfl the
steps get the nba
there's no steps for ufc you know it's
just it's just a tough go man
the best athletes aren't going to go
into it and they're also seeing how many
people are [ __ ] over
because for every conor mcgregor in the
nba they're all making more than come
right you know they're like you know
granted he had the 100 million dollar
fight but for the majority
all those guys are getting guaranteed
money connor's a wanted a
two billion fighters i mean even the
last who's the lie who who's
who's the twelfth person in the lakers
bench you think i mean who do you think
the
white guy who has terrible hair uh kruse
or whatever
but how and how much but the minimum
they're
making guaranteed money you know are
they the
you think people to put average mba
contract do you think the
average mba contract take away the top
three in the ufc you think the average
nba contract is better than
some people what they make in the top 10
not even close i think like 7.7 is the
average salary and that's guaranteed
right
the average ufc contract i think is 30
grand
so i so so so back me up a little bit
what's the mo
so so it is all they can do
look at that dude that's
earns about a hundred and thirty eight
thousand so a corn industry the average
ufc fighter earns about 138 000 on an
annual basis
well ahead of the 45 000 year average
yeah but they're only making it for a
finite amount of time
and is that 138 000 and that's after
they pay their manager
nope nope that's probably what on
contract they have on paper so 138 grand
and so and when you sign a contract for
the ufc
you signed by the fight it's usually a
six fight deal
six right deal so you you know ahead of
time
or can you negotiate say you kill it the
first two fights can you go you know
what dana i i want more of this third
fight
if you like let's say you have a six
fight deal and four fights in a contract
you're you're
fighting for a title you can renegotiate
but even then that's like up in the air
and is the sixth fight seems like a
[ __ ] lot
and it seems to be weighed two years
six fights two years yeah if you're
really active
six fights is two to three two two
fighting twice as much no way
no way like boxers don't fight nearly as
much is that because they get hit more
boxing's just a different animal the
thing when you think about the cards
there's not many fighters on there the
big names fight once a year maybe twice
a year
but why so i i think i did read that
that boxers just
get hit more they hit more for sure they
get hit more yeah do you think that's
why they don't fight as much
do you think a there's not enough thing
about like ufc has a card every weekend
until the end of the year like boxing
it's like
that was for recovery like how long does
it take to recover from a fight
it just depends how the fight went but
you know you're talking like
you know guys get 60 day suspensions 90
day suspensions
after a fight how long would it take you
say the what's the fight that you cancer
that beat you up
you know you're in camp for 12 weeks you
know then you do a fight you need a
break man
yeah again there's no off season like my
kids super half like the fighting's the
last thing you
you know much money they can make if
they're permanent permit premier league
soccer player
yeah because of the high speed i know
like
it's so guaranteed money or baseball
guaranteed money baseball guarant that
guaranteed money in baseball
is and the other thing no head trauma
and your worst injury what you
do john surgery you watch you watch
basketball you watch
you watch the i love the nba and tnt i
love
chuck and kenny and shaq together but
when they get up and run to the board
yeah to see how hard it is for those
guys to walk now they're big dudes
that's right
baseball players don't have the way
baseball you never hear
they don't have any of that limp or
anything
nothing but also the those guys like
charles barkley's what six ten no no six
five no barclays six five has to be six
seven
six five let's say six eight six i'll
say six eight charles barkley six i say
six five power forward
yes i know he did but he was one of his
thing was that he was super short 666.
yeah he was he dude what a freak to be
able to six six and jump amongst those
trees
mvp what a freak you know what one of my
favorite body type athletic body type is
the chubby
athletic dude that's why i loved chris
farley daniel cormier
dude that love it man when you're like
i'm there's no way that dudes in
anything you're like did he just do a
triple reverse flip first team all dad
man
yo when chris farley used to do uh uh
what are those called
handstands and cartwheels i'm like come
on man
el sasso super athletic izzy yeah
sasso's athletic that's cats like this
but if you're a big dude
you got calves yesterday like big you
gotta carry the weight yeah man you're
right
you know if you're over 300 pounds you
wear shorts in the winter you know what
i mean those guys yeah you're right
yeah that's right fat guys always have
giant cats
what is that that's will sasso's calf
get the why is it bigger than my thigh
his thighs are also not small
yeah that that his head his calves is
close to his size of his
face then will's killing man has his own
show now on tv how about that when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song